every time we turn on the news were
reminded of the things that separate us
borders cultures religions race but in a
darkened theater those differences seem
to melt away we laugh or cry as one
because movies aren't about countries
they're about being human
here are the nominees for Best Foreign
Language Film from Poland EDA directed
by pavel public offski from Russia
Leviathan
directed by Andrey swaggin second from
Estonia tangerines directed by Zaza
little Schatzi from Mauritania Timbuktu
directed by Abdul Rahman Cicero from
Argentina wild tales
directed by Danny Yan Zhi Frank and the
Oscar goes to
EDA
our God how did I get here we made a
thing about you so black and white know
about the need for silence and withdraw
from the world and contemplation and
here we are at the epicenter of of noise
and the world attention
fantastic you know life is full of
surprises so
so I'd like to thank the Academy I'm
honored surprised and overwhelmed I'd
like to thank the people who backed our
film The Producers Erik Abraham of
Portobello piata Jane Cho
Agnieszka of each of the Polish Film
Institute and many others they back to
oh and a u.s. distributor who did a
great job for very little money I'll
wrap up good okay so quickly to the one
and two my polish friends were in front
of the TV the crew who are in the
trenches with us and who are totally
drunk now and you were fantastic they
were brilliant you carried me to this
film and you are what I love about
Poland you're resilient courageous brave
and funny and you can take a drink and I
would like to dedicate it to my
late wife of my parents who not among
the living but who are totally inside
this film and they have lot to do with
the film and my children who are
hopefully watching who are still alive
thank you thank you Victor and Maria I
love you you are the main prize thank
you